Are you on Tech-Talk? Um, on and off,
I do find the algorithm to be unsafely
addictive. So.
I'm bingo. That's where it was going with it.
Any technology center for humane tech? Yeah, we were talking about Tristan here.
Yeah. And, you know, I think, for example,
like I was listening to a podcast with Tressa, Tristan Harris,
and I think it's interesting, whatever I'm saying, his name wrong. Um, and, um,
you know, the guy who invented the endless scroll, uh, you know,
and it's just like,
like a lot of this stuff is like really addictive and also like, um,
prioritizes, hysteria and rage, um, and also just,
uh, misinformation. Um, and you know, I,
I think it's like leading to not only like a political crisis,
but a mental health crisis. Um, you know, I was also,
I was reading this thing about how, like you go on Twitter or whatever, and,
and you, your brain is kind of getting the social chemicals and you're like,
feel like you're getting the social time, but you know,
you're not like there's different hormonal releases when you're actually in a
room with real people, you know? And it's like, you're, you're actually,
you feel like you're getting social a social experience, but you're really not.
And so it was like people are kind of having the byproducts of being quite
isolated. Um, not to mention the lack of sleep, like, you know,
like these things, like you're on your phone late at night.
Like it's going to be harder to sleep.
Like I think sleeping pill usage is going way up,
which is leads to less REM sleep, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And all of this like feeds into like mental health crisis on top of, you know,
all the political, political stuff and everything. Um, but yeah, I,
I it's quite concerning. And, you know,
I was thinking the other day I was talking to some people the other day, um,
about how, you know,
it's like we have global warming and then we have all these global warming
scientists or whatever,
or like we have pandemic and then we have all these pandemic scientists,
but then we have tech and in there isn't like a tech safety community.
That's super large. Like it's quite small.
Oh God, the extent that it exists, it's tiny.
Like it's Tristan people that he has on the podcast. And that that's a lot.
I think there's like Oxford, there's like some stuff at Oxford like there,
but it's still, it's like, it's just not, you know,
it's interesting that when people consider career in tech, it's,
it's all sort of like making the tech and none of it is the sort of like the
stuff about making. Yeah. And it's like,
especially like when we're getting close to AI and talking about AI, you know,
it's like, it's going to be super important to have like,
as many people working on AI safety as the,
as much as we actually just building AI.
Well, this is one of the things I said on, on the trail Grimes is that I said,
look,
some of the most powerful technologists in the world have said to me that they
want guard rails on AI because all the incentives right now are to go as fast as
possible because we're competing against each other and the Chinese and one of
us is going do something very regrettable. Uh, and, and so I would say to folks,
it's like, look, if Ilan is saying this, or, uh, Sam Altman is saying this,
then we really need to listen because these are not people that frankly
generally request guard rails like that. That's not good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, no, exactly. Like, like, you know, they, yeah.
Um, uh, I mean,
one of the things that really concerns me about the state of the government
right now, um, you know,
at the risk of sounding ageist is we just have a lot of people in the government
who are like very old. They didn't grow up with the internet.
They're not super tuned into technology. Like, you know,
there's people who are like getting there.
They're not even checking their email like in Congress and stuff, they.
Might never check their email and their title line.
Emails get printed out and they read the paper and then like, say, you know,
it's just like, this is like really concerning.
Like I don't think the government across the board has any understanding of
technology.
And that's part of the reason the Facebook situation is so out of control.
We can all see it's happening and you don't want to be a jerk to be like, Oh,
like, you know, the olds don't get this stuff.
But the fact is the average age of a us Senator is 62.
So like how many 62 year olds, you know,
that like understand like the mechanics and the social media companies.
Um, very few. And, uh,
there has not been independent guidance on technology-related issues in the U S
Congress since 1995, you know, 25 years. So,
so they're completely out to lunch on this set of issues. Uh,
it's corrosive for our democracy. It's corrosive for our mental health. Uh,
and I've experienced these social media apps in a particular way
where, uh,
I ran for president and try to use these apps to the best of my ability to make
my case and, uh, compete and generate a following. Uh,
and so I've benefited from them tremendously. Um,
but, uh.
Same, I rely on them completely to run my business.
Yeah. Um, but I can very,
very clearly see the downsides for users,
uh, where I think that I'm unusually good on them.
And even for me sometimes, like, I,
I sense myself lapsing into like a Twitter vortex or like a,
you know, like an hour or two will pass. Um, and,
and I'll look up and be like, Oh wait,
like I was supposed to do this other thing.
And it feels like you're being productive in a particular way and social in a
particular way.
Wasn't you reward, you know, the way it's been set up,
like as Tristan Harris or whatever says, like, it's,
it's just rewarded like, Ooh, like you hit the heart and go blue. Like,
you know, like the score, like there's, it's so set up visually to just like,
make your brain just be like, like tuned in and fed, you know,
it does feel semi productive or, you know, you're like, Oh, I'm learning things,
I'm learning things. But it's like a very shallow, um, comprehension, you know,
if you're getting a one sentence on a thing it's like, Ooh, like a fact, like,
are you even going to remember that? And there's no deep knowledge there. Um,
and I'm not saying like, I don't want to say social media is all bad.
Social media obviously is great. And you know,
there's been a lot of like political organizing and stuff on it. So, you know,
it's, it's definitely like, I'm not just saying like, you know, social media,
but.
There,
there are excesses and the excesses are hitting teenage girls particularly hard.
Yeah.
Yes, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah.
I mean the beauty stuff I think is like concerning.
Um.
And I believe that that Tik TOK is the most powerful of these in its own way.
Like I just got on Tik TOK maybe, um, two weeks ago,
three weeks ago. And Holy cow,
is that stuff powerful. Like you, you get in there and, uh, it's,
it's hypnotic, uh, you know,
you just end up seeing these videos of human beings, like, like dads.
Humans are drained. You want to look at human faces, you know, it's like,
like considering the amount of portraits versus landscapes, you know,
in the lineage of painting. Um,
like we want to look at humans like we're, you know.
I think it behooves most,
any adult who wants to understand what's going on with the younger generation to
try and spend a few hours on Tik TOK,
just to see what the heck the kids are doing. Um,
because it's like another language it's like another visual and digital
language. It's got a different energy and vocabulary,
different people. Uh, you know, it's like, it's fascinating because like,
you know,
I've been on Twitter now for a little bit and all the media and the journalists
are on Twitter and then you go on and take talk, and it's like just actual,
like kids having fun.
I think it's great for music.
For you, for music, it would be, I'm sure like a really useful fire hose.
You could just like, turn it on and like, um,
get stimulation in a particular way.
Well, in a sort of, I think a more natural, I mean, maybe there are, you know,
the dark forces of major labels pushing certain songs or whatever,
but like, I, as far as I'm aware, like,
I feel like it's just people like dig a song,
a song has a cool vibe with a certain movement.
And then like that song can kind of take off in a natural, organic way.
And I think that's pretty cool. Um, cause music is super over gate kept.
And I like, I think kick talk doesn't have that.
I don't know I might be wrong.
But there's a music discovery element and they're like undiscovered artists who
are just making their stuff there. Uh, and yeah, and getting found.
Are you going to run again, do you think.
I'm almost certainly going to run for something at some point I've been pretty
public about that. Um,
and I dare say it would be more fun the second time than the first time,
because we'd start at a higher base.
Um, but the, the problems are just getting bigger and hairier and nastier,
and I just want to try and solve them for your son, for my sons,
for everyone's kids. Um,
because you and I are in a where we're actually more able to make a difference
in the world and frankly, you know, like the vast, vast majority of folks.
And so, uh, like I take that responsibility to heart. So yeah,
you're going to see Andrew Yang on some ballot, somewhere, some campaign. Um,
I've got a couple of, uh, visions, uh, but first things first, you know,
we, we have, um, right now this, this might be too, uh,
uh, too, nitty-gritty for you,
but we were heading to Georgia for the Senate races, uh,
trying to win the Senate for, for the Dems. And then, uh,
you know, and,
and then I may end up in the administration trying to tackle some of the social
media problems you're talking about. Um.
That would be cool. Yeah. If you, if you,
if that does end up happening and you end up, like, I don't know,
like working with the center for humane tech people or anything like that,
like if you need any help, definitely hit me up.
Hit you up. That would be so fun. Grimes. What we do is we'd have this, um,
you know, this message that we need to get out. Um,
and then you could help and you could like make some freaking incredible,
like creative for it. Um, we'll hit you up on that, for sure like that.
And you could be like the champion of the,
of the humane technology movement or the human tech movement. I would love it.
Cool. Yeah. Well, anyway, I can help. Just let me know.
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.